[Music]
rachel there is a
new awareness
of investing details
in the last 24 months that i don't know
if i've seen in 30 years of doing this
really i always wondered that about
trends that you've seen because of that
just like i mean that's a young guy
right there who who actually really
knows his stuff yeah i mean he's asking
like detailed nerdy mutual fun nerd
questions right right and he really
knows his stuff and and you know that's
the good side of this investment
awareness stuff um and you and i were
taping a show this morning and we're
talking about the bad side is that
there's a right now there's a fresh
batch of people falling for get rich
quick like i haven't seen in a long time
yep there's a lot of get rich quick
stuff going on nothing down real estate
bitcoin
gold people are chasing they're chasing
quick returns quick quick money quick
easy money quick easy money
and they're gonna get burned they always
do when you put your whole life when you
bet your whole life on a wild ride uh uh
but it that has come in waves i mean i
when i was 22
in 1982 i went to a nothing down real
estate seminar yeah and that got me
started doing nothing down real estate
which i later went broke because of so i
was part of that get rich quick movement
the movement that followed that was the
infomercial movement yes
cable tv went bananas after that the
late 80s right and so everybody and his
brother dave del dotto and all these
guys had midnight tv every time you
turned on midnight tv there was any
channel there was a get rich quick real
estate thing on and uh it may have been
one more since then but uh from the late
80s to now this one they'll get rich in
real estate right now people are that
because real estate real estate oh
inflation inflation
and they're just you know they just lost
their mind freaking out so how much of
the
because there has to be an element of
what we've all been through
you know from 2020 and 2021
of the pandemic and all that right that
there's like this
i think it's psychological i agree like
there's something that has shifted
whether it's hey i want to control more
that i know more you know there's a
level of like the detail like you're
saying people are wanting to understand
their money a little bit more because
the fear of realizing oh my gosh what if
everything's like you know i feel like
there's that
and then there's the well you live once
like oh god who knows
yeah who knows what's going to happen
like let's just put the farm on bitcoin
yo
but the traditional investing plan yeah
feels better i mean i've even talked to
some of my friends about it and they'll
like question me and they're like so you
re you guys really you really only do
like your retirement you just do 401k
roth ira i was like yeah we have a
mutual fund and once tonight we do we'll
do paid for real estate on the side we
just have one rental right now but
i'm like and that's kind of our next
goal but but that's it and and it feels
it feels boring and it doesn't feel um
like you could be like you could be
doing so much more there's an urgency
to well this whole idea that all of a
sudden you had the entire population
realize we're all gonna
die you know and they hadn't thought
about it a bunch of them didn't think
about it and they went crap i'm gonna
die
and kova did that it scared the crud out
of people right yep and you go i mean we
all had at least a moment of that
somewhere in there like this thing could
wipe us all out sure nothing left but
the lizards and the dogs i don't know
but you know i mean it's just but uh but
but there's a little bit of that but
then but then other people stayed in
that psychosis longer sure but it made
us aware of our mortality and what it
did was some people's it panicked to
them yes and that's what's driving some
of this get rich quick yep the
get-rich-quick things i got in were more
greed-based
this one's more panicked i might not be
here long so i've got to get it
it's a quick urgency driving it and it's
really dangerous yeah because it's good
because you're not going to die like as
soon as you think you're going to with
that that as soon as that fear that
irrational fear that's driving this says
you're going to die and then you're and
so what's going to happen is you're
going to out you're going to live long
enough to find out how stupid you've
been
that's what you know like i lived long
enough to find out how my greed
stupidity was and it took me down i lost
everything to start again
you live you know the only way to avoid
that's die
you're but otherwise you're going to
live long enough to reap what you have
sown and man you have sown the whirlwind
and you're going to reap the freaking
tornado that's what you get you're going
it's going to come through your house
and you're going to go oh my god i was
so scared and i got in a hurry because
as soon as you get desperate right after
you get desperate you get stupid
it's in it's in the car
you do i mean we all do and there's a
there's a little desperation there the
bible says we're just here for a vapor
yeah just here for a second yep and
that's true
but it's not to panic you
it's to say i'm going to be diligent i'm
going to be serious-minded
wise but i'm not going to brood over it
i i i might make it two days i might
make it two decades but i'm not going to
brood over it that's what i've got left
and that's my time
and the time that i have here i'm going
to be wise with it and i'm going to be
functioning
thinking long term not thinking yolo
right absolutely and we were saying this
morning even
until something has a long track record
and that's the problem
with a lot of this stuff even you put
crypto in this that
the tracker is just not long enough to
go and bet everything of these people
you know that are cashing out of the
market completely and going into these
these industries that don't have a
proven track record and that's what you
want to gamble and you want to set fire
to a percentage of your net worth
possibly uh because you think
something's kind of cool you want to buy
a single stock in tesla okay you want to
buy because that's oh now you're well i
mean well but i mean
there's a difference between the car and
the company
okay this is
just and but tesla has a much better
track record today than say it did 36 or
48 months ago sure absolutely it's much
less risk now because it's lived longer
that's right that's right it's it's
stayed alive yes you know and so it
might be the next iphone right now it
might be the next apple i don't know are
you gonna get a tesla no i didn't say
that i said do you have it do you have
an iphone i do i do have an iphone yeah
but i'm just saying but the it's not a
point of consumer consuming it richard
i'm talking about investing in the
freaking company messing with you i know
so you're talking about investing all i
see is me driving a computer and i
really want to want to drive that tesla
you want to drive a battery i'm sorry
you say tesla and i
hey you don't have to deal with it if it
doesn't make noise it's not a real car
wreck oh it is but it's faster than your
car if it has to have a it has to have a
loud muffler or a redneck is not allowed
i will race you it's redneck law redneck
constitution says it must have a loud
muffler
you can so your rednecks are not allowed
to drive a battery we're not allowed
changing your family tree for the good
of electric cars
[Music]
i don't even know what we're saying i
failed as a father just invest in mutual
we're
funds
[Applause]